triste fin pour le rorqual à bosse qui
pendant dix jours a émerveillé les
montréalais tu qu'on souhaitait que son
chemin pour j'ai retourné en mer mardi
6h15 simon lebrun pilotes maritimes est
à la hauteur de varennes aux commandes
de porte conteneurs sur le fleuve saint
laurent
on a perçu un point noir qui normalement
et paul puisqu'on connaît bien l'endroit
côté navigation dans sa prochain on a
constaté que c'était la baleine qui est
échoué sur un banc de sable loin au fond
les curieux n'ont pu que constater son
triste sort d'abord pas des champs du
fauchage raisonné qui le connaît mais je
pense que était garé près de prince au
milieu de vie après le baleineau agit de
deux ou trois ans avait été aperçu pour
la première fois près du port de
montréal le 30 mai dernier
l'animal qui n'est pas fait pour vivre
en eau douce était probablement
désorienté il avait été vu pour la
dernière fois dimanche près de pointe
aux trembles
c'est la crise de loi de la nature et de
la sélection naturelle de parcours c'est
très triste a constaté mais je pense que
tout ce qu'on avait à faire c'est de
laisser cette baleine le plus d'espacé
possible pour essayer de retrouver son
chemin malheureusement le rorqual à
dériver sur le fleuve durant la journée
suivie de près par des agents de pêches
et océans canada
en attendant les ressources nécessaires
pour le sortir de l'eau dans la suite
des choses il va avoir une espèce dans
ce cas est une invite à une
investigation par nécropsies pour savoir
qu'est ce qui se passe qu'est ce qui
s'est passé au temps des ponts compte
qu'est ce qui s'est passé une tâche dont
se chargera une équipe de la faculté de
médecine vétérinaire de l'université de
montréal directement sur la rive ici
valérie michaela bayne radio canada
montréal